midi le pâtissier se fait une dernière
fois une beauté il fait partie de la
caravane du tour de france les quatre
véhicules de ce groupe hôtelier ont
parcouru les 3400 14 km de l'épreuve
cycliste
il ya énormément de préparation on se
rend pas toujours compte mais c'est une
vraie logistique parce que le char ne
peut pas rouler sur une route ouverte
donc on est obligé de l'amener avec un
camion un porte char en tant que chef
d'equipe c'est toujours une petite
émotion dès que je passe la ligne
c'est vrai que j'ai 7 cette émotion qui
monte d'un coup en me disant c'est bon
j'ai réussi à mener l'équipe jusqu'au
bout plus de 6000 goodis par véhicules
distribués sur le bord des routes par
les 11 membres de l'équipe de quoi
mettre en joie les spectateurs c'est la
troisième année que le groupe hôtelier
présents sur la grande boucle vrai qu'il
doit la part du public
est-ce qu'on sent vraiment quelques
conduire un capital sympathie autour de
logis l'hôtel tout le monde veut avoir
son cadeau donc là on a des belles
étiquettes de bagages pour emmener à
travers toutes ces destinations en
france et en europe des belles
expériences mais il attendait également
qu'on puisse avoir un échange
la caravane s'est élancé vers 14 heures
heure à laquelle les premiers cyclistes
professionnels ont fait leur apparition
et un public qui a répondu en nombre
parmi les plus applaudis le slovène
tadej pougatchev double vainqueur du
tour et le champion du monde le français
julian alaphilippe un autre but von arx
bien sûr puisqu'il vient de belgique
nous avons commencé nos vacances mais
nous ne voulions pas rater cela te
laisses moi j'adore mark cavendish
parce que ça fait un petit moment que je
me suis donc du coup voilà
j'adore mark cavendish et puis là je
viens de voir al akili jamais fait
départ donc franchement c'était une
bonne occasion quoi c'était une belle
occasion de venir
il fait chaud la caravane vanne possible
c'est la quatrième année consécutive que
la grande boucle s'élance des yvelines
un partenariat passé avec le département
jusqu'en 2023
c'est une façon aussi de pouvoir
remettre aussi recommencer aussi à vivre
après c'est ce confinement c'est un
plaisir de voir vraiment où les gens
aujourd'hui sortir sortir faire la fête
et envie de partager encore des grands
moments quand on a effectivement fait ce
partenariat avec avec la hes-so c'était
aussi une façon de pouvoir promouvoir
aussi nos territoires pour mouvoir le le
patrimoine promouvoir aussi tous nos
belles villes aussi des yvelines ayant
on peut que s'en réjouir
le peloton s'est élancé peu après 16
heures pour les cent huit derniers
kilomètres de ce tour de france de trois
semaines avec une arrivée bien connu
[Musique]